[Music]
all right so did you guys know number
one did you guys know who this guy is
his name is Arnold Schwarzenegger have
you heard of him yep he sounds familiar
it's better than coming says this guy
AKA a seven time Mr Olympia y right zums
zums what he said all right is very
notable at that time for being the
youngest person to go pro bodybuilding
and by way of doing that was 20 years
old and he was the first first person at
that age ever to go pro
bodybuilder so he did his first
competition at 20 no no he turned pro at
20 so he probably did his competition at
14 15 with the normal ages to get like a
pro card to turn pro so yeah like uh so
someone like Jared who who he just
turned Pro maybe a few years ago so it's
like the size that you need to be at Pro
on stage you probably need to be like
probably between 220 and 250 stage which
means in real life you're probably 260
to 300 wow cuz like you're you're like
shredded and you're like 250 so it takes
a long time to build muscle cuz you can
only put on like anywhere from like 2 to
like 5 lbs of muscle a year so that's
why it takes a long like it takes for
like a general bodybuilder that's
massive takes at least a decade or two
to get to that level do you think during
his generation they were juicing though
and then the stand were the was the
average standards different like you
know how now everyone looks like crazy
ax they uh they were juicing too but way
way way way way less so their standards
were probably less right or like their
average weight and then like like what
he stepped on stage with what he stepped
on what he won first place with back in
the day would probably not even Place
top 15 now wow which makes sense though
right cuz he's flabby he's flab yeah
yeah right like like like ho Grace you
probably get tapped off by a 16-year-old
right now yeah it's the same thing like
with but how spectacular that was
especially to be age 20 and do that he
held that title and that record of being
the youngest person to go pro he's held
that record for 57 years wow wow so no
one has beat the 20-year-old going pro
until now o oh is that new kid Anton or
something Anton Yeah so basically this
19-year-old Phenom finally took that
record of being the youngest person ever
GoPro his name is Anton
ratush or something like that so like
now I think what you're seeing is uh
Elite genetics with Elite Training with
steroids at a young age with Elite
steroids honestly probably Elite
steroids too Elite steroids and this is
him right here
19 years old cuz imagine like if you can
only put on like maybe like 5 lbs of
muscle like pure muscle a year how long
do you you know like think about how
many years you have to be training your
[__] he probably been training since
three I don't know about that young
but do HGH since he was 5 years old how
is this better damn dude hey this is
this guy's 2-year transformation though
he looks like a throbbing boner dude
this is his 2year so he had crazy
genetics this looks better dude so
that's 10 lbs of muscle difference no no
no so the theme with steroids is
accelerates I'm giving you natural rates
with steroids it accelerates that but
then the part of the genetics is not
only do you have to be have the uh
potential to build muscle for people to
be in the prob bodybuilding space you
need to also have your uh genetics be
very responsive to steroids as well so
it's like double yeah I see but you can
tell from his natural cuz I'm assuming
two years ago he looked at that you
could tell from his natural muscle
bellies like his muscles just look like
they want to grow wow okay I can't wait
the muscles are like right yeah like you
just look at some people's muscle
bellies and you're just like oh [__] you
lift some weights and what do you think
about my muscle bellies they're they're
like mine they're very
average do you think as extremely
average yeah they're pretty average dude
average
average i' like I've been Lifting for 25
years and I look more like [__] than
when he just started when he was like
15 I can't tell the
difference I got positive body
dysmorphia go he's like look like both
of them
look [__] I know I look good what
what's the point yeah me up for an
hour and then later you see yourself and
you're like oh I don't look like that
what oh man I got to work out Bro [__]
why does not I don't look like the
mirror is the veins look like a real
it's like it's a other guys it's hot
right now I think it's like veins and
like muscle striation so like if it's
just smooth then that's one thing you
just flex your Che at me and I like that
was an accident okay well very
subconsciously so the veins thing isn't
if we're talking about you get a big
muscles if you're talking about strict
bodybuilding judging they don't really
care about veins what they do care about
is conditioning which is like how dry
you look like you want to look like dry
like like your like Saran wrap on like
like the [__]
human yeah yeah yeah like you want to
look like that at the luxur right like
the human body exhibit you want to look
like ran wrap on muscle and it just so
happens that when you're that lean that
your your veins pop out and you're also
dehydrated and you can barely a
conversation yeah yeah strong and you
need a dozen donuts right before dude
thatd be SI a brain fog
pageant dude when they're stepping on
stage SATs they're all the foggiest
they've ever been that's the why I
didn't realize like cuz we've been
watching Miss Universe in Miss Miss
America for years and all these they say
the dumbest [__] ever but now we know
why cuz we talked to Bart on Jak for
like 5 days and like dude this guy was
dumber than [__] he's actually a pretty
smart
guy post show takes about 3 to 4 weeks
to recover I found out cuz your body's
like literally like at the brink of
death yeah and you're at that that point
for like quite some time holding it and
it's just being pummeled with large
pizzas over and over but and that so
you're so exhausted and you're like
you're so dried up all you can say is
World Peace yeah and people make fun of
you but we know it's there's it's deeper
than that actually yeah they've been
fasting they have no water in their
brains that's true honestly that is a
good take man thank you it's like you
look at them like they're just idiots
all the time but it's like they're
nervous they're emaciated Bart can jump
in on any conversation unless he's been
[__] He's dried up yeah yeah what's
that that's that guy Anton or
transformation Dam dude how old was he
on the left I I think that's 2E
transformation two years how the [__]
does he come he turn from lamb to Lion
Foster Farms to the Hat
pami yeah no I don't think that one's
two years lamb to Lion [__] chicken
to [__]
Ox that's crazy oh no that's not the two
the other one I showed was twoyear
transformation that one was just like a
change in his body as all I never tried
to get that buff do you have any need to
to be that buff no show the guns my boy
no dude we can't do this again we're not
doing this you're on your way man is St
got some big he curls 50s my boy I I had
him I had him away only my
wife I don't have aspirations for that
because number one I think that uh that
would make it very difficult to dance
well I don't think so check out K green
what if you time it perfectly lock this
[__] what if you time it perfectly where
by the time you reach like Peak buffness
you don't even need to be dancing no
more and I also think I also think the
hard thing is like like you said
genetics for me to get to that because
my genetics aren't that easy or good I
would have to work so hard to maintain
it I think you have better genetics than
us you might have good genetics man you
might but then he always gets
sick I that's lifestyle yeah I don't
know if that's that's sleep this guy
party and L [__] every day yeah L
[__] every day why are we being so
cool to Anthony this is weird say
something quick what what is you just
shut up for a second even us out
even what's now they have to cut now
they have to cut all that sh what's your
uh what's your ideal physique yeah yeah
yeah and me who you asking yeah did you
ever have like you know so many people
like I want to look like Fight Club like
Brad Pit Fight Club did you have a ever
have a ideal physique no I as much as I
honestly I got this from you and so I
don't want to give you too much flowers
because I hate you but other than that
um I really want to stop carrying about
an ideal physique I want it to just be
good lifestyle habit oh T if it's good
lifestyle then the physique going to
come comes as a result yeah cuz cuz I
think when I was younger I would always
want a certain physique and if I got
close I would slack off you know what I
mean if you're so like goal oriented
then you might get there and then it's
not like a lifestyle that you wanted you
just wanted the physique and then you
kind of give up and I just go into
fluctuations but if I can literally
choose to just have it be like my daily
a part of my identity then I think the
physique will be good enough if you want
to be like the shallow fun answer I do
think I want to be a little bit bigger
and leaner than what I'm right now I
think it Tak I don't want to be like
buff yeah I it takes a couple of shallow
and fun answers and like Journeys and
New Year's resolutions or whatever to
finally make it a lifestyle but then uh
I once read like this phrase it was like
your body is a reflection of all the
decisions you make and I was like yep oh
[__] this right here cookie and this
right here is 225 [__] bench press
cookie and bench press let's go baby
Cookie and bench press so I was like oh
[__] yeah your lifestyle is just your
collection of uh decisions that you make
daily if I look like a pregnant man but
like a wrestler by the shoulders that's
tight that just means I go to the gym
and do this and I go home long as you
did it on purpose yeah that's cool I
think if I keep a six-pack Nina would be
very you got a sixpack I think you keep
a six pack yeah okay but then when you
bul cuz you want bigger [__] chest
it's holiday season show the fans ask me
in
February mark your calendar tell me how
you got yours tell me how you got yours
my six-pack
heavy dieting and heavy working out
almost two times a day minimum six times
a week all right I do the same thing but
that's why you're so hot right now but I
cookie but I cookie I don't really diet
that hard so I'm lying to I can't tell I
think you diet medium you'll be [__]
jacked
bro everybody knows how [__] hot you
are Joe no but I don't want to be hot I
want to be functional yeah he's married
he doesn't either that's a bad answer
dude God forbid those are on opposite
sides of the scale yeah it's a shame
it's a shame can't do
both